foreign
would you rather if you were forced to
right now gun to your head
would you rather eat a regular Dunkin
Donuts meal with a big sugary coffee and
three big Donuts or smoke one cigarette
oh man is this a roll your own tobacco
or is it a Marlboro oh you get to pick
oh I would definitely roll my own
cigarette and smoke it right there yeah
I'd choose a cigarette too yeah for sure
wait but but we got to balance this out
because we're comparing three Donuts
[Laughter]
we were like tag teaming on Josh earlier
uh last week because he was he brought
this up and me and TK were like you want
to go get some donuts I don't I can't
even tell you last time I had a donut
but like I will absolutely eat a donut
every once in a blue moon in moderation
same thing with cigarettes I don't smoke
cigarettes but like maybe once every
five years like you know someone rolls a
cigarette and I'm like oh you know what
I think I'll have one of those but yeah
it's something that we don't obviously
do on a regular basis I haven't smoked a
cigarette since I was 12 or 13 years old
I smoked one and a half in a day and
that was the last year I was in a skater
gang and my friends had cigarettes yeah
let's do it I remember I smoked it down
by this little creek after a McDonald's
meal or something it was just stacking
all the bad things and then I quickly
realized when I had the second cigarette
I don't want to be a smoker and I
stopped it I've only smoked one and a
half in my whole life so I don't smoke
we're all your own I have ever but
um yeah it's an interesting thing but
also to add to that Donuts are cooking
seed oils yeah so but I think that your
point is well taken
these these people are demigods of our
society and here they are promoting
unhealthy food I mean
Kim Kardashian did an ad for one of the
Beyond Burger nuggets or something and
people were roasting her the fact she
didn't even eat it and it's not healthy
and it has seed oils and methyl
cellulose which is essentially wood
fiber anyway yeah and so when I look at
a commercial like that the reason I
bring it up and compare it to smoking is
smoking is something we've all agreed we
know it's not healthy Once Upon a Time
however
there was four out of five doctors
prefer camels or whatever else right and
so we pretended it was healthy for a
period of time I don't think many people
are pretending Dunkin Donuts is
particularly healthy but I think we're
dismissing it as oh it's just a treat or
I deserve it or whatever but I remember
growing up I would get donuts pretty
much every morning it became my
breakfast and what I'm trying to to
illustrate here is if that is a regular
meal it's probably
more destructive than smoking in many
cases
you could certainly compare them I mean
they're they're both very destructive
for humans it's it's it's a problem for
humans but one of them is
completely fine and accepted within
Society right hey it's the same thing
with alcohol yeah I mean there's yeah
there's a lot of things that
20 years from now may not be so social
socially acceptable did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free